-Guys, finally, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we as a group
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you a series
of different tweets.
Then we're all going to vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want, but we're
going to see the results
live here on the show.
Higgins, Roots,
you guys have your clickers too?
-Got it.
-Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
It's a shared experience.
Okay, you guys ready for this?
[ Cheers ]
Alright.
The first tweet is...
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
-[ Chuckles ] Wow.
-"Get in --
Get in that locker, nerd!"
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Here we go.
Everyone has made
their decision.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results here.
[ Drum roll ]
Alright, okay.
Half and half.
Okay.
Lukewarm reception to that one.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Tepid, tepid.
-Alright, this next one is...
[ Laughter ]
See, is it corn pops?
Okay, I feel like everyone kind
of made their decision fast.
-Yeah, this one
is going to be a little low.
-Let's see the results.
-Whoa!
That's well-balanced.
-No, are they getting --
they get --
[ Laughter ]
That is well-balanced.
Let's take a look at
this next one. Here it says...
[ Laughter ]
As faster you can get on there,
the better.
Alright, Tariq is thinking about
that a little bit.
So, I think this might do better
than 90-something.
Let's see the results
on this one here.
[ Drum roll ]
Alright, that's not bad.
There we go.
139, I'll take that.
-Wow, 1-3-9.
-Yeah, that's good.
Alright, here we go.
The next one says...
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
See? That was a yes.
-It does a little bit.
You're like, "Ah,
still got take Monday haze."
Okay, here we go.
Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
There you go!
-Oh! There we go.
-I knew that one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's the winner right there!
I'm going to post this!
[ Bell dinging ]
I'm going to post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet.